SO, YOU RELEASE THE ANTACID
INTO HERE.
IT EXPANDS.
THAT EXPANSION OF GAS PUSHES
WATER OUT OF THIS ONE INTO HERE,
AND WHATEVER VOLUME
WE GET IN HERE
IS HOW MUCH GAS WAS PRODUCED
BY THE ANTACID.
AIN'T IT GREAT?
I LOVE IT. LET'S DO IT.
Narrator: THERE'S MORE THAN
ENOUGH WATER TO MAKE THIS WORK.
JAMIE PULLS
THE QUICK-RELEASE MAGNET,
AND THEY'RE OFF
AND BUBBLING.
LOOK AT THAT!
IT WORKS!
AND THEY'VE GOT A RESULT
IN SECONDS.
SO, IT LOOKS LIKE ONE PILL
PRODUCES ABOUT
75 MILLILITERS OF GAS.
YEAH, ABOUT 80.
WELL, NOW MY QUESTION
WOULD BE,
"DO TWO PILLS
DISPLACE 160 MILLILITERS?"
DOES IT SCALE PERFECTLY
LINEARLY?
DOUBLE THE GAS
FROM DOUBLE THE PILLS
WOULD MAKE SENSE,
BUT SCIENCE
IS RARELY SO SIMPLE.
WOW!
THE VOLUME OF GAS PRODUCED
SCOOTS PAST THE 160 MARK
AND CONTINUES TO CLIMB.
THIS ONE'S LOOKING
LIKE 275.
TO SEE IF
THE TREND CONTINUES,
THE NEXT LOGICAL STEP
IS TO TRY FOUR PILLS.
DOUBLE THE TWO-PILL RESULT
WOULD BE 550 mL
OF DISPLACED WATER.
AND BEFORE LONG,
JAMIE'S WISHING
HE'D BROUGHT
A BIGGER BEAKER.
IT'S ACTUALLY GOING
MORE THAN --
MORE THAN DOUBLE.
IT'S CLEAR
THERE'S CO2 A-PLENTY.
BUT THE MYTH
DEPENDS SPECIFICALLY
ON THE PRESSURE
THE GAS GENERATES,
SO THAT'S WHAT
THEY'LL MEASURE NEXT.
TESTING PRESSURE
IN THREE, TWO, ONE.
OH, LOOK AT THAT.
THEY START OVER
WITH ONE TABLET,
AND AGAIN, THE RESULTS
COME QUICKLY.
WHAT ARE WE GETTING HERE?
1.9? 2 PSI?
YEAH, THAT'S ABOUT 1.9 --
JUST A HAIR UNDER 2.
NOW FOR
A MINI MOMENT OF TRUTH.
TO SEE IF PRESSURE, LIKE VOLUME,
INCREASES EXPONENTIALLY.
ALL RIGHT.
TWO TABLET PRESSURE TEST.
IF THE PRESSURE
JUST DOUBLES,
THE TWO TABS
WILL FIZZLE AT 4 PSI.
BOTH PILLS ARE STILL GOING.
BOTH TABLETS ARE STILL BUBBLING.
2 PSI IS ROUNDLY PASSED.
2 1/2 PSI IS ON ITS WAY.
2 1/2 PSI HANDILY PASSED
BY BOTH TABLETS,
AND NOW ROUNDING UP
ON 3 PSI.
3 PSI.
WILL WE GET 3 1/2 PSI?
3 1/2?
ANYONE FOR 3 1/2?
YES! BOTH PILLS SEEM
TO WANT TO GO TO 3 1/2 PSI.
ON OUR WAY TO 4.
4 PSI. 4 PSI.
GO! GO! YES!
PASSING 4 PSI,
THE EXPECTED
LINEAR EXPANSION RATE
OF THE TWO TABLETS,
AND IT SEEMS THAT
THEIR EXPANSION RATE
IS, IN FACT,
EXPONENTIAL.